hi it's Justine this is ro hello
yesterday when we were filming I started
with the video office like hey guys it's
ro we were having so much fun and in her
defense she had had a lot of sugar we
tasted a whole bunch of candies so great
we were on a sugar high and it was a
little later we were like getting really
silly
we were but today we're gonna do
something very simple I thought it would
be really fun to do a Q&A because people
are always asking us questions in the
comments how did you meet
what's your favorite color I feel like
is always a very common question
today I asked you guys on Twitter to ask
us some questions
and guess what I've got question
questions the first one I thought was
very appropriate so we did do a Q&A
before on Rennicks channel which was
very fun that wasn't real life so I may
have answered a few of these but you
guys might not have seen it so just in
case this question is how did you guys
meet how did we meet hmm well it's kind
of a long story so I loved her content
and when I started my channel you have
been doing YouTube for awhile and she
had a big fancy channel and I was just
starting and I was too nervous to ask
her to come bake with me I made a cake
that I thought you would think was cool
and it was the best ever it was a Call
of Duty cake cuz I know that she loved
to play that game tweeted it and I like
tagged her in the tweet I was like you
might think this cake was cool or
something and I did and I wish that I
would have filled my reaction because I
was freaking out I was like sending it
to my sister I wasn't ever really like
oh my gosh don't go this amazing cake
like this is so cool and this was way
before I ever even tried to bake
anything
I'm so happy you liked it every that was
like our first interaction was on
Twitter
you didn't even slide into the DMS I
didn't then I was still too nervous I
was really shy because I didn't know
really anyone in YouTube community I
think I knew maybe two people and we
ended up meeting in person and like a
YouTube thing and at the YouTube space I
don't remember what it was it was one
casual space is it a panel I don't know
but I remember I got your number and
yeah I will have you and
is Roseanna nerdy nummies so that's how
we met yeah and then I just blew her up
all the time as soon as we exchanged
info I was like we're friends now oh we
are and here we are
yeah and I'm sending you like funny
pictures and gifs and mm-hm
I even met anybody not on the internet
in a really long time like in real life
first I have to be honest my whole world
isn't how YouTube like all my friends
are youtubers and we need to get out
more
whoa expand our whoa I don't know I know
a few musician really but they also are
on YouTube well if they got a VEVO
channel does that count a grey zone yes
well we'll discuss okay next question
Oh what do you consider touring together
I would more than consider I would say
yes they do bring Maddie because he's a
DJ what do we do I don't know we need to
have a show or something
we can't just just get on a bus um well
okay so my dog is DJ one sec we've got
one thing okay I can cookie to any she
could she perform maybe she'd dance
she's real cute she is super cute
talents it's okay we can work on it we
can work on it she can be the tour
manager she can sit okay we'll have to
figure two in our show would be which
this could actually lead into a second
question that I saw what does it what
was it any hidden talents well I just
told you mine that's juggling and it's
not really that hidden because I do it
all the time you like it but I didn't
know you can juggle until we were
hanging out this is kind of a hidden
talent I can bark like a dog
you ah oh my gosh it's weird
let me hear it do you want to it's okay
it might be loud hello to myself editing
okay okay I have to see it up cuz I
gotta really just like get in there okay
okay okay
your hidden talent is you can bark like
a dog yes you can also juggle but people
know that yeah let's hear this tour is
gonna be incredible yeah sound effects
and everything we got it do you think
cookies gonna freak out maybe so cookies
asleep right here next to me she may
wake up okay she would cookie hi honey
are you scared he's very concerned this
is a true Italian because she thinks she
thinks it's real it's okay good evening
sir nobody I'm fine err okay what did I
say I don't even know what I said oh my
gosh oh my oh my honey she's very
concerned just stating everything's okay
let me yeah we have to we have to
console her oh my it's not real what did
I say just something that you real to
you like a good Jessie thank you
coz she thought it was real totally
fooled my hidden talent would be well I
like to say you know people know that I
think I did it I did one song but it was
like an acoustic pop song where it's but
what they listened opera wait what but I
haven't made a video of it yet but I'm
classically trained and I sing opera I I
can hit really high notes really that
vibrato and that legato but wait I
didn't help this yeah yeah I'm serious
do you want to give us like a little a
little something oh my god I believe
more tea but okay look it up I do it
have o mio babbino Caro what does that
mean oh it's like Oh dad it's it's oh
interesting well it's Italian ah Greta
and the girl wants to marry someone and
she's trying to convince her dad that
you know she what I did marry Laurie was
going somewhere else it was the way
she's gonna marry okay no no it's there
[Music]
there is another
[Applause]
I'm gonna a copyright strike list you
shot
[Music]
at this table even though you were
friends with an opera singer did you
at least samples you having a flip
[Music]
I am in shock right now okay well I
guess on tour I'm just gonna be getting
UT do you think the kids would enjoy an
opera like number that's the thing is
that operas just not as popular as pop
music so maybe if we made it like Oh pop
opera you know when you mix anything
with pop it really works like it could
be rock pop it could be good yeah like a
medium opera like Maddie to be up there
like doing a little DJ scaling I've
always wanted to sing the song from
Fifth Element I don't know what that one
is they have an opera singer and Fifth
Element and I don't even know if some of
the octaves are possible because I don't
she's an alien
hmm you know yeah we're not in the same
vocal range it's like a human bull but
it's just like maybe you can just like
you know lip-sync that's totally fine
we're okay with that are at our show
like this is not like I had no idea like
what I love that we're learning stuff
about each other this is insane what's
your favorite color combo color combo
what do they mean by that ya know would
be you know like a beige color or like a
green and like an olive I mean I would
say my favorite color combo I've matched
I love white and black but those aren't
colors per se
I've had a pic of color I would say like
pink and black well like for decor I'm
really liking white grey and blush like
rose gold for like home decor but in
general I'm really festive and I love
the holidays Halloween is one of my
favorite holidays so a black and orange
combo for Valentine
or red and green for Christmas yeah yeah
I think those are good but I hope we
answered your question yeah so Alexis
you never read ones names like this Alex
Alex if you're asking if we have any
advice on parent slash dog hood I'm
assuming you mean dog parents yeah
because we're dog mom yes we are we've
got a little Maddy little cookie I'd say
the biggest thing is Wow I mean
definitely giving them attention but I
think the hardest part is a lot of
people will get dogs as rescue dogs
which you should always rescue do not
shop always adopt is sometimes when you
get a dog later in life you're gonna
have to break a lot of the habits that
they already have but training from a
very young age is so so important I'm
saying that all dogs have different
personalities but there are different
breeds do you have different general
temperament for sure I mean you know
like even like poodles like my dog like
it'll be John like they're all very
similar mm-hmm cookie is a French
Bulldog and they have a reputation for
being very stubborn and that is very
true so I heard when we were training
her had to train very young and mean to
be very consistent and it took almost a
full year to potty train her to go
outside but now she will never go in the
house I know I mean I travel a lot so
like Maddy has been traveling since he
was like eight weeks old
he's been so pleased a great travel he's
a pretty great traveler but he also
doesn't like children very much like
these small little kids and babies so
it's hard because it's one of those
things that it's hard to break because I
don't want to like be like hey can I
borrow your child to see what my dog
will do so it's sometimes a hard thing
to break but man it's the best thing
yeah I like being a dog me to Lourdes is
nice to be patient in consistency they
love having a routine yeah which Maddy
does not have a routine he's at my house
he's at my sister's house he's with like
strangers all the time now here did he's
here yes with cookie they love to play
together now off to show you guys his DJ
skills cuz they're pretty impressive if
you haven't item
Yuja never put animals on the table you
know I do even an exception that they
were to I had done the pug sit on the
table because I was scared he would jump
out of the chair what's up come here
come here
DJ see you man guns DJ come on you got
this buddy
good boy good times DJ here you go good
boy okay come on Mattie
sounds DJ come on let's go you've got
this time to DJ good boy yes come on
let's go wait don't want them to marry
can you go another really good piece of
advice is to get a dog when you're ready
for one like I wanted a dog for so many
years
yeah I wanted to wait until I really had
the time to take care of one exactly and
give the dog the best life and I mean I
thought that I was ready but then a lot
of things popped up he was sick for
almost an entire years my pretty much
for entire year stop traveling I had to
cancel a lot of jobs because I was like
this is a responsibility that I took on
so now I have to take care of himself it
was worth it though whatever is that
worth it so worth it life with the dog
is amazing it really a cookie makes me
laugh every day let's see what else
we've got
we've got Wolf Blitzer who is asking
what is something you guys want to make
together the most on nerdy nummies
maybe something Super Mario Odyssey
themed super mario de si is such a fun
game like I'm such a huge fan of Mario
and you love Mario and you love talking
about this so much yesterday yeah just
talking about this yesterday I was
staying up until like 3 or 4 a.m. which
for me is very late like I don't stay up
late I go to bed at 9 o'clock but I just
couldn't put the game down you were
telling me that I know I'll be really
fun that's a good idea
yours may be like the Mario
yeah maybe we should make them Mario
hacked what about so classic the Bowser
and Mario my wedding cake Oh cupcakes to
go around it oh my gosh that would be so
cute the wedding cake is pretty cool too
oh it's so great no spoilers no spoilers
I'm really excited now I feel like I've
drink ten cups of tea mom I need a sip
look at you look at the size of this
coffee
it's tea it please oh yeah see I could
if I could I was drinking tea I drink
this much coffee I would flip the table
let's see what else we've got
oh here you want here asking who was
better at Mario Kart just need well I
mean I don't know yeah that's down we
might have to play one day so we're
playing Mario Kart at your house cuz
that was like with a group of people one
it's kind of unfair yeah cos you know I
was so mmm I'm real mediocre I don't
come in last place but definitely not
first that's basically like my life
motto like I don't want to be the worst
and I'm totally fine not being the best
just like okay it's like it'll be here
at Mario Kart you know I like you
something goes low because then I can
achieve that but you're really good at
Mario Kart I'm not bad you don't want to
brag because that's not her style she
doesn't like to brag but she's really
good at Mario can't beat Matt though
which makes me very upset she's insanely
competitive when he goes to that game so
this one Oh save the best for last
rikiei wants to know what would your
ideal first date need and what do you
look for in a potential boyfriend
okay jobs if you tell me oh your dream
first date be I am NOT gonna lie like I
love a good dinner and I love a good
wine good food I'm also fine doing
absolutely nothing because I mean I feel
like as I've gotten older I just like to
sit I don't know I mean like dinner some
wine you know dinner wine ah a chilly
evening very chill so you could get to
know each other or even if it's like
you're unsure like you can just go for
coffee that's always a good one you can
like feel it out you're like Melissa
something I don't want to get well yeah
and it says first date trade deal first
ah so what coffee date might be really
good because it's casual just in the
waters casual not a lot of pressure
definitely not inviting a first date to
my house so that's off the table so that
okay yeah and then a dinner I feel like
might be too long and then the wine may
be too formal first date coffee coffee
date that sounds good or a dog park date
they have a dog so body a good because
that can be shorter if is hell working
out
yeah you could get coffee and then go to
a dog park that's good and then you can
see if they like your dog and if your
dog likes them even Maddie's dogs yeah
yeah instincts that we don't even know
about I feel like sometimes they pick up
them on stuff that we don't know that's
true i 100% agree and if you don't like
dogs like it's clearly not gonna work
out would you have an ideal first date
ideal first date would probably be
something like we're talking about I
really don't like to be swept off my
feet like a row man someone who comes
badly who's super suave was like roses
and just over the top usually makes me
very weary like people are like fast
talkers or like sweet talkers to
charming I usually go whoa you're a
really really suave and then red
flags go off in my head like true and
then you can do some googling and then
you can research them and then you can
get a background check and then you go
search all of their Facebook and then
you can see if there's a police record
and you got to really do the guac before
you have the first date so you basically
have to have an internet first date
first to do the research to be jel
something like yeah I would like a
coffee date well thank you guys so much
for watching make sure you go check out
Roe's channel and be sure to subscribe
we've done so many fun videos together
so many lately so just love it do a
quick search and you'll find something
that hopefully you will enjoy that's it
we'll see you guys later bye
[Music]